Well, hello there. I am Ahmed and I'm
going to vibe code an AI agent built
with AI primitives while I deliver this
talk, right? So, let's start here. One
of the most common AI agents that we've
seen in production is there's some data
and there's a chatbot as an agent and
you're trying to chat with that data
because well, all of these LLMs are self
attention algorithms anyway, right? So
you go to chai new and you say something
like chat with
PDF and let's see what happens. Chai is
now going to vibe code an AI agent for
you. It's going to build it on top of AI
primitives instead of an AI framework.
And as that is happening it just takes
like a minute. How about I tell you a
little bit of more about who I am and
what are we talking about today. Right.
So uh look at perplexity cursor v 0ero
uh lovable bold and even now chai you
will see one common uh theme across all
these production ready agents that are
you know building millions of agents
millions of gener you know millions of
people are using them and there's this
one this one really good trend that you
can pick up that all these AI agents in
production are actually not built on top
of any AI frameworks because Well,
frameworks do not really add that much
value. They're bloated. They move super
slowly and they they're filled with
these abstraction that nobody really
needs. Instead, you should be building
on top of AI primitives. This is what my
entire talk uh is about today. I am
Ahmed. I've been around the blog for
quite a while. If you use WordPress,
NexJS, NodeJS, React, you have probably
using my code because I've contributed
to all of these software. I have also
built uh hundreds of open source
packages mostly automation CLIs with
NodeJS and created a shades of purple
code theme all of which are downloaded
like 40 50 million times uh you know a
year and I've gone up to you know as uh
as technical as you can imagine I've
contributed to NASA helicopter mission
and in the past I have been a VP of
developer tools VP of engineering Google
developers advisory board member all I'm
trying to say is I am deeply technical
I've gone through this phase of working
with in building frameworks and now why
do you think I am talking about
primitives I think primitives have this
native ability of working really really
well in production like Amazon S3 is a a
really good uh example here Amazon S3 is
a primitive where you can upload data
and download data and they scale it uh
massively they're not building a
framework for object storage it's a very
simple thing it's a lowle level
primitive you can use to build lots of
things right and that is what we are uh
talking about here today my journey in
LLM actually started with in 2020 when
Greg Brockman himself gave me access to
GP3 GP3 was just like what uh maybe a
month old model and I I had already
started building uh you know something
like GitHub copilot which uh launched in
2021 a year later
right even now you know we've been
building it uh things and agents for
like I don't know 5 years building and
deploying and scaling AI agent remains
to be the biggest pain there is and I
think everybody has a different
definition of AI agents but this is my
take at it I think AI agents are just a
new way of writing code everything we
know of how we used to build code how
you used to build coding projects uh or
SAS all of that is changing because of
AI and because of agents and it's it's
just big enough. It's not it's it's just
a new way to write code. It's big
enough. You know, if you try to put it
inside of a framework, that abstraction
might not be enough. Instead, how about
we build small building blocks that are
useful across a stack like something
like threads? You know, every agent
needs to store some sort of context or
history of conversation. So, threads
would be an awesome primitive and we
build that, right? So, why not build
that? Why I think that is important is
because here's my belief. I think most
of engineers are going to become AI
engineers. This you can already see with
fullstack AI engineers, web developers
and front end developers, they're
quickly transitioning into this AI
engineering role because they are
shipping a lot of product with AI and
they are building stuff with uh
different LLMs or whatnot with vector
stores and this and that. Even DevOps
engineers and ML engineers are now
shipping product. So when everyone is
building as an AI engineer, what we are
trying to do uh here at Langbase is
improve their experience. We want to
become the fastest possible way for you
to build a production ready AI agent.
A lot of people I think start with this
painful way of building AI agents where
they pick up a framework which is filled
with uh you know obscure abstractions
which are really really hard to debug
and then they have to figure out how to
deploy and scale those agents. We think
the other way. I think if you are
building on top of predefined really
good highly scalable AI primitives
especially composible primitives that
come with a piece of cloud in it like uh
you know memory memory is an AI
primitive which is like you know like
memory which has a vector store in it
you can throw in I don't know terabytes
of data inside of memory and it will
automatically scale so if you build an
AI agent with that memory or with that
parsing chunking or threads or tools
infrastructure what you get is a
serverless AI agent that automatically
can do the heavy lifting for
you. But what does that actually look
like? Let's take a look at what is
happening here today in this talk. I'm
going to share and by the way like I'm
going to probably you know already done.
I'm going to deploy this before you know
we move forward. I am going to go over
eight different AI agent architectures
that are built purely with AI primitives
instead of a framework. Look like look
at this you know I said chat with PDF
and it figured out that well you need a
memory for storing this PDF which will
have a vector store and you need uh an
AI agent an LLM uh which will be used to
ask questions from this PDF right so it
went ahead and did this you know we need
it created a memory created uh a way for
you to generate answers an agent on top
of that memory right this uh the flow of
this very simple I want to retrieve a p
some PDF content and then generate the
answer right and you know it's already
done as you can see these lines the
first step is to build that memory and
we are using a primitive here
langbase.mmemories this primitive is
where we will put the user uh input the
you know the question that user is
trying to ask is the name of that memory
the PDF uh document memory uh if you go
here you will find that memory in This
all of this can be built uh with API as
well. What I'm going to do here is I'm
going to go to I don't know uh mls.com
about and
ms.com talks. Uh this page has u
information about me. This one has
information about my talks like the one
I'm giving right now. And I'm going to
throw all of these
as PDF files in it. So I have already
saved them on my desktop. So I'm going
to just quickly grab
them and upload here. I've also I'm
going also going to do this API key lang
base. So I'm also going to throw a PDF
version of this particular file into the
memory. As you can see uh this is the
doc about Langbase uh how to get API
keys from Langbase u my talks and my
about page. All of these files are right
now being processed which means uh a
parser primitive is converting these
files uh from PDF to text and then a
chunker primitive is going to chunk
these into small pieces of context which
are going to be used in a similarity
search. If I refresh these you will see
that all of these files are now ready.
Right
now now let's go to this agent code and
see what is there. All right. So we are
going to ask a question from this
memory, right? Which will return back
some memories. And these memories are in
the second step. As you can see here,
this is what we are going to use as
context, right? This is generate answer
step. And in this step, we are basically
going to create an AI agent that is
going to use that context to answer the
questions you have. Right? Very simple.
Uh it has also uh Chai has also you know
built an agent app for you which makes
it really easy to use but you can also
go ahead and use you know uh an API with
whatever programming language you
prefer. Let's try the agent app. Let's
ask it something some uh very simple. So
who's the
founder and his last three
talks? There you go. Right now this
information is in two different files in
our memory which was parsed chunked and
embedded automatically using those
primitives and you can see the answer is
already here. I'm the founder here are
you know the last three talks I did uh
and how do I get an API
key? This should probably also give me
uh an answer on how to get that API key
from that other file that we had. um
added in
there. There you go. How how you get an
API key. There's a bug. You can actually
go to the app mode and vibe code a fix
for this bug and this app uh will be
fixed. You can also, you know, make it
public or whatnot. What's happening
behind the scene here is most
interesting. You know, uh I think every
agent needs all these primitives that we
are building, right? Primitives are like
you know memory which is an autonomous
drag engine a workflow engine that is
built purpose built for multi-steps
agent threads where you store and manage
this context and conversation a parser
to extract the context and a chunker to
split this right and using all these
primitives you can build almost any AI
agent we actually did a lot of research
on stateofiag aents.com where you can
read a lot about how people are building
uh agents what type of primitives they
are using and what type of uh LLM is
required in doing really well in which
type of industry right let's now go over
different AI
primitives and different agent
architectures that use different AI
primitives so the first most common
architecture that we see is an augmented
LLM augmented LLM is basically an agent
it's an agent that is going to get an uh
you some input and it's going to
generate some output which will have an
LLM. It will have some way to
automatically call tools so it can
connect to MCPS or call different APIs.
It will have access to threads. Thread
is another AI primitive which will which
is where you can store the conversation
users are having with this agent or the
context of this agent uh you know which
might be you know completely completely
asynchronous right uh thread uh of
context a scratch pad like for example
when you're booking a flight there's
certain set of information that you kind
of keep in your header on a scratch pad
like I'm going to land here I'm going to
go do this and that and that is useful
ful when you are you know booking that
particular flight. So you can use thread
to store that uh you know memory like
context and then there's memory the
long-term memory of you know different
events or whatnot. This could be
terabytes of data that you want to
search when you're using this agent
right uh which obviously requires more
context and requires you know vector
store. So in this example, in this
augmented LLM, we see tools as
primitives, threads as a primitive, and
memory as a primitive. And you can
basically build almost any type of AI
agent with this augmented LLM
architecture. As you can see here, lang
pipes or agents provide you with that
primitive.
Now let's uh look at what type of agents
and what type of architectures can you
actually build uh using that augmented
LLM that I just showed you. Here's
another one. So prompt chaining and
composition where you use multiple
agents as you can see the purple blocks
here working together. You get an input
and agent creates an output and based on
that output you basically decide if you
want to go forward, right? Maybe you got
an email uh and you figured out if that
was spam or not. And if it was not spam,
then you used another agent to write a
draft email in response. And you can uh
take a look at, you know, what's
happening here. There's a summary agent,
there's a features agent, there's a
marketing copy agent. This code is plain
JavaScript or TypeScript if you will,
right? You can see here um a summary
agent, uh this is a feature agent, and
this is a marketing copy agent. they're
all going to work together to generate
an output that you need based on an
input. A more interesting one is uh
something like agent router, right?
Where an agent uh or an LLM router that
you build basically decides which other
agent is needed to be called next,
right? Let's see what this is what this
architecture looks like in production.
None of this uh we are going to build
all of this with AI parameters. None of
this is built with a framework. We're
going to basically create three
specialized agents for different tasks.
One is a summary agent for summarizing
text. The other one is a reasoning agent
for analyzing and explanations and then
a coding agent for obvious reasons you
know when you need to write code and all
these are built with different LLM. So
summary is from Gemini uh reasoning is
with deepse uh llama 70B and coding is
with clots on it. Right now let's look
at this code. This code right here is
only going to use AI primitives and you
will build your own uh AI framework on
top of it instead of using a botted AI
framework. Right? So as you can see
here's a routing agent. Router is being
told what the job is. It has access to
all these agents and it is supposed to
respond back with valid JSON and picking
which of these agents is going to do the
job for us. Right? And here is the
documentation of a very simple set of
agents. A summary agent uh uh a summary
agent, a reasoning agent uh right here
and a coding agent. Right? Now all of
these are going to run together. All of
this as you can see is just plain old
code. There's nothing new here. you can
easily write this. This there's no
magic. There's nothing to learn. It's
basically you're just calling these
agents together and one of these agents
are going to respond back with which
next agent you need to run uh you know
for the task. So the task is very
simple. Uh y days are shorter in winter.
Now let's go ahead and run this code.
So the main agent the router the scene
agent has decided that it needs to run
the reasoning or you need to run the
reasoning agent uh to for this
particular task. Right? Obviously you're
not writing code here. You're not uh
writing summary. You can see how the the
decision maker made the right choice and
then you pick up the same uh uh
reasoning agent that he had built based
on this answer and then throw that input
in there and here's the you know answer
of why answer of why days are actually
shorter in winter. Don't get distracted
by this answer by the way. Right? So
another very common architecture for
building agents we see is running uh
agents in peril. This is absolutely
simple to use. Uh there's no abstraction
needed for JavaScript. Uh in JavaScript,
you can basically build a set of agents
as you can see here. Here's a sentiment
summary in the scene maker agent and you
can promise do all of these agents and
they will run in parallel.
My favorite however is this agent
orchestrator worker where an agent
basically decides to orchestrate and
build any number of worker agents that
are going to solve a problem which is
then synthesized by another agent.
Right? This is exactly what uh a deep
research agent architecture looks like.
So this one is really good. What we are
going to do in this is we are going to
create an orchestrator agent that will
plan and create
subtasks for worker agents and these
worker agents are going to work on those
subtasks. Right? Let's see how that look
what that looks like. So this is the
orchestrator and the entire thing it is
going to do is give us back this type of
response with subtasks which are going
to be uh things that you know these
worker agents are going to do. It's a
very simple worker agent. It's going to
get a subtask and it will complete it
right. So let's look at the main input
here. The input is write a blog post on
benefits of remote work. I care about
productivity, work life balance and
environmental impact. Let's see what
happens here. So the orchestrator here
is going to generate a bunch of
subtasks. As you can see that is what it
has done. So write the introduction uh
write a section on productivity on work
life balance on uh environmental impact
and then write a conclusion. So as you
can see here there are like one two
three four and five subtasks. So this is
going to take five workers worker agents
to complete. Uh as you can see here,
this is the first worker agent. Second,
um
third,
fourth, and here's the fifth one that is
writing the conclusion, right? And
finally, we are going to synthesize all
of this into one
thing. Uh look how simple this is. This
is like what like 90 lines of code and
there's no uh framework here. You're
basically building very simple uh you
know agents worker agents in an
orchestrator agent and your promise.all
all running all of them uh and the data
is just flowing through that right
there's there's no need to build a
complicated abstraction layer on top of
this because maybe uh you know in a
couple of months you'll see that agent
this agentic workflow will get even
better with LLMs understanding how to
run these worker agents if you're using
any AI framework in abstraction that you
are you know kind of stuck with uh when
these agents in with when these LLMs
become much more better at these agendic
workflows, you'll have a very hard time
migrating off of it. So, it's much
better to build on top of primitives
instead of building on top of a
pre-built abstraction, right?
uh we'll probably also going to uh take
a look at this evaluator optimizer where
um an LLM is used an agent is used to
generate a response uh generate
something and this uh something this is
uh probably I don't know let's say a
marketing copy this is going to be
evaluated by an LLM as a judge right
which will either accept it or reject it
with feedback I'm just quickly going to
go and run this you know here's a
generator which is generating ing uh you
know um some product description. Here's
an evaluator which is going to either
say accepted or provide with uh feedback
based on the prompt you write here right
and what we are doing is we are writing
an eco-friendly uh description for an
eco-friendly water bottle for conscious
melanin. So um the first agent takes a
stab at it. Um and the evaluator
actually says no uh you are basically
missing uh you know the point with this
particular type of audience the
eco-conscious millennials right and
provides very specific feedback uh on
what to do and how to improve this and
this evaluator should be built by
probably the best possible uh LLM you
can think of for your space of what you
are trying to evaluate if it is related
to health you're probably calling a
memory and you you know, you're doing
all that you need to do to make sure
this evaluation is really good, right?
And the second iteration, as you can
see, uh is very well uh very uh is
generally well done based on this
particular
feedback. Finally, uh obviously you can
call tools with this. We can skip that.
Uh I think you can probably easily
understand that. The most interesting
one is memory. Memory is when you upload
data, you create a memory agent. You
upload the data and then you retrieve
that data and ask questions which is
exactly what we saw here in this code
where we created a memory. Let me go to
the agent code where we created a memory
uh uploaded the data manually which you
can also do through an API as you can
see
here and then an agent was used to
answer questions related to that data.
This is also a very common pattern for
building agents.
Now that you know all of these AI
primitive patterns, you can build pretty
much 80% of the most complicated AI
agents out there. And I've done just
that like uh I've basically asked Chai
to build me a deep researcher like
perplexity where it actually went ahead
to uh build things to analyze the query
uh do a web search consolidate the
results and then uh create in a
response. It is using exa here and all
the code is here. I can actually just
probably go ahead and ask it something I
don't know what's the latest with open
AI something like this and it's probably
going to go ahead u send this basic uh
query and start doing that deep
research. I've also built things like
for example oh let me go back. I've also
built things like uh I wanted a receipt
checker which would do OCR and since
chai or lang didn't have an OCR
primitive I found one from Mistl so I
asked it to use Mistl OCR and gave it an
example of how to use it and that is
what it exactly did here so it's
processing the image with OCR and using
GPD 4.1 right now extracting uh from the
user input whatever is needed and also
using uh MR OCR latest model on top of
right to do a double fall back and
really improve the OCR um based on top
of the image we are going to send it
right let's see you know I have an
example here I think this is Paulo Alto
$15 delivery or something yeah there you
go total paid 15 bucks and city of Paulo
Alto it's a parking ticket I guess it's
analyzing the result right
now and there you go city of Polo Alto
and 15 bucks.
Right? Similarly, I built an agent where
I like u let me add an image URL and let
me chat with that image. Right? So, I
just added this uh image URL. Uh what is
the
expression of the person in this
image? Okay, let's give it a go and see,
you know, what
happens. There you go. uh eyebrow is
raised uh quite skeptical and curious
which is what I generally look like in
real life right so uh in the code for
this is pretty easy analyze the image
using GP40 uh a vision capable model uh
takes the image here uh takes the image
URL here from here passes the input and
that is pretty much it right it's a
pretty simple flow as if you ask me so
well this this is pretty much it and
we've seen like you know it's May 30th
and you can see almost every other
minute there is a new agent being built.
I saw somebody building a dental cost
advisor uh a business swamp pro uh I
don't know a task refiner all sorts of
amazing uh agents are being built with
chai and chai is building all these on
top of AI primitives instead of building
it on top of a framework uh that would
have some abstraction that you probably
don't even need when building agents
right so the idea is very simple all the
production agents
that we know of when they are not built
on top of frameworks. What good a
framework would do to you in a fastm
moving space when every other week there
is a new paradigm, a new LLM, a new
problem being solved already that used
to take a lot. Uh why not build your AI
agents on top of really good AI
primitives? uh and you can either build
those AI primitives or you can use the
pre-built AI primitives that we built or
some of our you know friends uh are
building over at different uh companies
u and also uh if you really enjoy uh you
know w coding give chia uh you know uh a
try. It will try to use the primitives
it knows and it will also try to you
make it really really easy for you to
quickly build an agent deploy it and use
it right away instead of building a
silly demo that may or may not scale
right. Uh I am MLS and I am always
hanging out on Twitter. I would love uh
your feedback. I would love to know, you
know, what you folks think and what you
prompt, ship and ship with our AI
primitives or not. Take care. Ciao. Use
your code for good. Peace.